all right now that's the equation that
they give us but let's read the actual
question it says sketch graphs of the
following linear equations like this by
finding the X&Y intercepts
okay so this is a bit different right
before we had this kind of equation we
have y equals blah blah blah blah blah
and that was really good it's really
nice when you've got it in this form
could you just read the gradient
and you can read the y-intercept there
it is
okay but this doesn't look like this
anymore
it doesn't say y equals anything right
it's all mixed up and jumbled up okay
so it's not in the form that we want but
we can still find this information I'm
gonna do this first find the x-intercept
right I'm gonna use exactly the same
trick you some of you are asking to know
what I did over here okay let me remind
you to find the x-intercept right what
you do is you let y equal 0 okay I know
that's a little bit confusing because
you're like x and y it's kind of swapped
around it's a little bit backwards okay
we're gonna do in Reverse to find the
other intercept sir I'm gonna try and
find the x-intercept right now let's get
another color so let y equal 0 see this
is my equation right so I'll write this
equation but instead of Y alright 0 ok
I'm substituting it in let's go minus X
plus 6
lots of 0 equals 120 dad all right
okay what am I done in this night I said
well I want to find the x-intercept and
the way that you do that is you're that
y equal 0 that's this analogy I was
giving you before of like I'm at sea
level
okay so I've put in y equals 0 right now
what's 6 times 0 0 cool so this is just
minus X plus nothing I don't have to
write anything that's equal to 120 so
what's X what do I have to do here
so I got two ways to do this I can add X
to both sides but then I have to move
this 120 over the other side as well a
better way to do it is to divide by
which I do by mine hmm I want to get X
by itself right surely I should divide
by minus one right cuz would that get
rid of the negative and that's that's
what I want to get rid of right if I
divide by X I don't get rid of I don't
get the X by itself over here fine
divided by six I don't get the X by
itself over here so I'm divided by minus
one that just gives me this it's minus X
divided by minus one what six times zero
so there it is I can't that's what I did
here that's how I got excited
see I've got x equals something and an x
equals something here okay so now I've
got my X innocence this is the x
intercept okay you guys ready to keep
going
yep does it make sense if you wanted to
go back to understand gradient factory
okay all right I'm going to find the
other intercept now and I do it exactly
the other way around
to find the y-intercept right instead of
having x and y I'll have Y and then X
okay so I do it exactly in Reverse so
I'm going to write this equation again
but instead of y equal zero all maybe X
equal zero everywhere I see an X I'm
gonna put zero up here because minus
zero plus 6y
equals 120 okay so this minus zero on
the front what effect does that have on
the whole equator nothing nothing
doesn't do anything right
6y take away zero is still six y so just
right
Superboy okay now I want to get the Y by
itself so what do I do to both sides I
divide by six okay so now I have a
y-intercept 20 years okay now we're
ready to draw a graph right so get
yourself up a little set of axes do you
use your ruler I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
this direction because I'm much [ __ ]
for some yep
let X equal zero so I do missing there
you go it's a little bit up okay neck up
I'm gonna take these two values and I'm
gonna check them on my graph I was a bit
silly
I should pay more attention to my
numbers because it's gonna look a little
bit like this one again see how that's -
hundred twenty that's a really far to
the left okay so which axis is which
which one's the y axis again is it up
down left right up down also that's okay
you're probably thinking you gonna what
okay so x equals 120 where's that sorry
it's negative a hundred twenty so it's
all the way over here is really far away
right so I'll put that in as minus 120
that's my x intercept now going why the
set is 20 that's high there's not nearly
as as far away as this right so I'll go
up about like so okay I've got these two
points you just have to join them up
like so
okay that was better than my previous
attempts so there you go um wasn't
transcendent that's it
the last thing I should do just to be
neat about it is to label it right so
this is the equation for this graph so
I'm gonna put that on there - X